well the war on Christmas is totally
fake they always tell you that on TV but
it's also underway again and get off to
a hot start last week with the left
launching a new offensive against
Rudolph the Red Nosed Reindeer now the
war machine is opening up new fronts
faster than we can keep up or trying an
elementary school principal in Nebraska
has banned a whole swath of Christmas
related items from his school that would
include Christmas trees elves
Santa and red-green color combinations
how about candy canes are they allowed
no they're banned too why because
they're in the shape of a J which
represents Jesus mark sign is an author
and columnist he joins us tonight you
know I just want to say again the war on
Christmas is not real marks to stop
talking about it you're right right now
the Fox guy yeah and Charlie fictitious
okay I'll bite I'll bite on that and go
back a couple of centuries Tucker you
know the separation of church and state
when the founders came up with it is
basically that they didn't want
President Washington being the head of
the Church of America as the Queen is
head of the Church of England that's it
they didn't want the Archbishop of
Virginia sitting in the Senate as the
Archbishop of Canterbury sits in the
House of Lords and like a lot of same
concepts it's metastasized into
something utterly insane and when you're
actually banning colors when you're
banning two of the colors on the color
spectrum red and green so there's only
orange yellow and blue left you're
bonkers you're nuts you've you've flown
the coop of reality you are and you are
living in a more bizarre fantasy than
Santa and his reindeer and his elves
could ever come up with you just ban
starboard and port how dare you okay
another thing a Minnesota State
University professor tweeted this week
that Mary the Virgin could not have
consented the conception of Christ and
that God was behaving therefore in a
quote predatory manner that professor of
salary is paid for by taxpayers also
tweeted himself decorating a Christmas
tree with satanic ornaments have you
taken any of his classes mark Stein no
and the reason is this is the thing that
this is because fifty years ago
this kind of shallow banality would have
been the province
of a drunk undergraduate at 3:00 in the
morning I mean basically the idea that
that God has gotten the Virgin Mary back
to his pad and she's saying I really
must go and he's saying a baby it's cold
outside and put some records on while I
pour I miss the days when atheists were
at least intelligent enough to take
seriously what they were porting to
knocked down the the stupidity and
banality and shallowness and reductive
Necedah small comment on the state of
atheism in America and it's not even
brave
they'd never criticized Jeff Bezos the
richest man in the world or Apple Tim
Cook or no Google they suck up to people
in power and then beat up on
evangelicals and call themselves you
know counterculture yeah yeah and they
don't seem to make us met the same kind
of ramadhan jokes as they do miss miss
jokes no it's all bad isn't it I wonder
why that is
Tucker so you mean this community
college professor whatever this guy is
it's not attacking Mohammed no no no
this is the card this is cardboard this
is cardboard couch by the way from
teachers even if you're an atheist the
greatest glories of Western to go back
to what Heather was saying the greatest
glories of Western music art
architecture painting were in the cause
of Christianity you're cutting out body
jelly and all the rest of it well the
university wouldn't exist without it so
right no no no no - Shelly - frosty
that's very shortly mmm so good rude
rude Rudolph and Leonardo all gone all
gotta go it's the Cultural Revolution
see em thanks for